speaking of the perception of time
i remember you said this is obviously
known that the more adrenaline you have
in your system let's say it peaks you
feel like time has slowed down
well i wasn't sure i said that i mean
that you certainly there there's just
this some kind of
popular assumption about um
time slowing down under various sorts of
high arousal situations
right and actually time here is
something that i've
been working on just for the last uh
four years or so and it's really due to
i had this
one of my colleagues warrick roseboom an
australian cognitive scientist to
join the group in 2015 and brought
a deep interest in a wealth of expertise
on time perception so he's been
leading our work there and uh
one of the so one of the i think really
fascinating
lines of argument that he's making and i
i agree with him it seems right is that
um is to push back against this idea
that we
experience time in virtue of having a
little clock inside the head
a lot of work in this area
boils down to an assumption like that
that that
there's time unfolds in the world and
certainly when we when we're making
judgments about time
we often get it wrong if there's if we
measure an objective duration
and then we ask people how long that
duration was
people can be wrong about it and they're
systematically wrong
in the same way they're systematically
wrong
about many other things in perception
and you know for instance there's
there's a very general
law in perceptual psychophysics where
people
are biased towards the mean of the
things they they're judging perceptually
if you you know if you like see a whole
load of
circles of different size um and then
you're asked to judge the
size of the next circle you'll be biased
towards the mean of the
circles that you've already seen it's
called regression to the mean
and in time perception you do exactly
the same if you
if you experience a load of different
durations let's say just beeps of
different lengths and you're judging
the duration of each beat you'll be
biased towards the mean
and this is a very useful
signature that there's something like
bayesian inference going on here that
you are
your perceptual judgment about a
situation
is based not only on the sensory data
but on your prior expectations
about what's going on bayesian inference
is simply this way of combining what you
already know
with what new information you have to
come up with the best guess when you say
that
we're biased toward the mean do you mean
that of what we experience first so it's
like we take a sample of our first
experience and take the mean of that and
then our later experiences are then
biased toward that mean
or do you mean we're biased toward the
totality of the experiences means
uh well this is a this is a good
empirical question right we
it might depend so
it's it probably depends on the details
of the experiment
over what time scale the brain is taking
the mean
um and it's gonna it's gonna vary
by task by by context and and so on
um in this case i was really talking
about
fairly short time scales where you can
show that you're just on the last one or
two minutes of what's going on then
you'll be biased
in your next decision uh towards the
mean of that
but then you could make the argument
although it's much harder to demonstrate
empirically
that for instance maybe my experience of
duration in general is biased by the
mean of every experience that i've had
and my ancestors have had and so on but
of course i can't manipulate that in the
lab so
in the lab i can only manipulate context
over relatively short time scales and
and see what the effect is
but but sorry when this is very yeah
securities route to this idea of
of time slowing down and um
so firstly for me there's a very
interesting distinction here between
perception of duration
and the experience of the flow of time
that's interesting so there's a
difference between those two
yeah i think there is it's you know we
can perceive something as lasting a
certain
duration but the experience of
just how fast time is going
is different um it's different in this
again in perception in general we can
separate
the change of perception from the
perception of change
so i can experience my perceptions
having changed but then the experience
of the change is itself
a kind of perception there are various
phenomena things like change blindness
which show this very nicely that
it's something if i'm watching a just
like an image which i'm assuming is not
changing
but actually maybe the background color
changes very slowly
you'll find that people won't notice
that change
and sometimes say people say there's a
paradox here because
they didn't notice their change but
they're now looking at
a different thing so how does that work
and i think that the resolution is to
say well no their perception has changed
but they didn't perceive the change
because change of perception is not the
same as perception of change
so i think the similar thing plays out
in time as well the perception of
duration is not the same thing as the
perceiving time flowing um
and it's much harder to to get an
empirical handle
on the flow of time my favorite
experiment here i don't know if you've
come across is by
a guy called david eagleman and and
chess statson i think was his
uh researcher at the time and so they
they had this idea that if indeed
my perception of time is slowing down at
moments of
high arousal so let's go back to that
how can i test that well so they they
sort of thought well if if time is
slowing down then maybe if i do have
some sort of
internal clock that's the ticking of
which is
underwriting this perception then maybe
there are more ticks of the clock
going on in a particular objective
duration
so then i would experience time as
dilated
and so that was the reasoning and so to
test it he had this beautiful experiment
where he gave people
watches that were specially designed so
they would flash numbers
but so quickly that if you just looked
at them now you just see a blur
you wouldn't be able to decipher what
the numbers or the letters were
and so he then had people bungee jump
while looking at this watch
uh several times then go to crane
look at the watch and and the hypothesis
was well
if if subjective time is slowing down
because an inner clock is increasing its
its
rate is frame rate let's say then
maybe this these people should be able
to read what's being
reported back yeah yeah what do you
think happened
i would imagine they did right no they
didn't
no it was okay it was a really
interesting failed experiment i mean it
wasn't failed because
it came it was the evidence was pretty
clear
uh but it was it sort of ruled out that
simple explanation
that yeah this clock is speeding up
because people you know subjectively
still had an
experienced dilation of time but it
didn't seem to be due to this
acceleration of an internal clock
and of course i think the reason for
that following my colleague warwick is
that because there isn't an internal
clock